con la mira en las relaciones entre
Europa y China durante tres días y
Manuel macron y Úrsula ponder Legend
intentarán reanudar el diálogo con
Beijing en línea con el discurso de la
presidenta de la comisión europea del
jueves pasado
creo que no es viable ni redunda en
interés de Europa aislarnos de China
nuestra relación no es ni Blanca ni
negra y nuestra respuesta Tampoco puede
serlotte ambos líderes están Al filo de
la navaja con china el principal
objetivo de Manuel macron apoyarse en
Beijing para dar vuelta a la guerra en
Ucrania según el Eliseo china es una de
las únicas potencias capaces de poner
fin a la invasión rusa pero hace 15 días
se reunió con Vladimir Putin en Moscú en
Manuel macron Espera disuadir a Beijing
de entregar armas a Rusia Pero según
varias cancillerías occidentales es un
objetivo difícil de alcanzar otro eje de
la visita es al comercio macron está
acompañado por unos 60 grandes jefes
franceses entre ellos los de air y
veolia en la agenda firmas de contratos
para permitir un mejor acceso al mercado
chino Después de tres años de pandemia
un refuerzo de las relaciones económicas
deseado por china
está dispuesta a trabajar con Francia
para hacer de Esta visita una
oportunidad de promover nuevos
resultados en la estrecha y duradera
asociación estratégica global entre
China y Francia
el último punto sensible los Derechos
Humanos según el inicio se espera que
Manuel macron hable de la suerte de los
huijuris en chinyang una región del
Oeste de China donde Beijing es acusado
de perseguir a esta minoría ética